well let's turn now to a topic close to
many people's hearts how the pandemic
has transformed the world
of dating the popular dating app hinge
says dates on its site were actually
up 14 worldwide in 2020 compared
with 2019. more than 40 percent of all
hinge users
have been on virtual dates and 65
want to continue using video chats in
their dating lives
after the pandemic now that the us is
opening back up we spoke with four
singles about how the pandemic and being
vaccinated has changed their dating
lives
i'm maya i am 26 i live in los angeles i
am
single and i am a comedian and an actor
i'm
eric i'm single and i live in new jersey
i'm 27 years
old i'm nicole i'm 22 i'm from miami
florida
and i'm single i'm max i live in new
york city and i'm single
31 years old for the first couple months
when we were in full lockdown it was
just
a no-go that was an absolute no for me
like some people i met in person other
people
i would just be like talking through the
apps and then like zoom and whatnot
i was a little bit nervous pre-vaccine
to
go out on actual dates and stuff so i
wasn't dating a ton during the pandemic
dating was a big part of wanting to get
vaccinated i wanted to get back out
there
start mingling with people again in fact
i really tried to talk my way into a
date with someone i was getting
vaccinated with
i think we all have a little bit of
social anxiety
after being in quarantine for so long
but i'm happy to say that things are
feeling a little bit more normal when
things started first opening up it was a
little odd
because i wasn't used to being in like
crowded spaces and talking to a bunch of
people like that
but it's like riding a bike you never
really forget it people have different
levels of comfort with what they want to
do on dates now
so certain people don't want to go to
concerts yet or go to baseball games so
making sure that people are really clear
with what you want to do on a date is
really important
since i've gotten vaccinated i would
definitely say dating has
become almost all in person no more face
time dates
thank god honestly i'm just excited to
be able to like go to bars again and
meet people out in the world
i think hawker summer is in full swing
and i'm happy to be here
what a good ad for all of them right i
know
find their find their profiles now right
on hinge
we're joined now by logan yuri director
of relationship science at hinge
i love that title director of
relationship science
logan thank you for being with us this
morning thank you so much i'm so happy
to be here talking about dating
i know right so i think it's really
interesting that during the pandemic
as you said dating went up on hinge
itself
a lot of times these dating apps get a
bad reputation but it looks like 75
percent of people are looking for an
actual relationship yes that's exactly
what we found and what we were really
interested in because there had been a
lot of rumors of this
shock girl summer or waxed and backs but
what we're finding
what we're finding is 75 of people spent
the pandemic
thinking i don't want to be alone i want
to find someone and now they're ready to
get back
out there and really date well i at the
beginning of the pandemic i wasn't
dating anyone and in the middle of the
pandemic i did start dating
somebody at first i was using the apps
and it wasn't really working
for me i ended up getting set up on a
date but
that whole face time the calls the setup
i actually really preferred it because
you got to know people before you went
out on an actual
socially distanced date do you think
that's going to stick around
yeah that's exactly what we've heard and
so 65
of people who have been on a zoom or
facetime date tell us that they plan to
continue doing this after the pandemic
and
that's because they felt really safe
they could do it from their comfort of
their home and it's this
low pressure vibe check it's a chance to
say are we a good match before we meet
up in person
and now you you're able to show that
you've been vaccinated on your profile
which i think is funny it's like your
age
if you have a pet and now if you're
vaccinated how's that working out
yeah it's been great so as you have up
here um
singles who say specifically that
they've been vaccinated are getting 30
more matches and that's really
meaningful and so we love being a part
of
helping get the word out there about
vaccines and why it really matters for
dating
so logan you're also the author of a
book called how not to diet
alone you bang on the nose there you
caught me you caught me yeah
what's interesting is people clearly
don't want to die alone however they
also are fearful of getting out there
and dating again in fact a slim majority
of people on hinge feel a little bit of
afraid why is that
yes i'm really glad you brought this up
and so 75
of hinge users are ready to get back out
there and find a relationship
but 51 of them are experiencing photo
which is foda fear of dating again
and this is exactly what we saw in the
clips that you played where
people want to meet someone but they're
also experiencing social anxiety
about their rusty dating skills and even
maybe being in public on a date
so i find it really curious um that
that you see that there are people that
are still using these apps and you
probably expect that more and more
people will continue to use them so
what would that look like you're in
charge of relationship science um
i'm from days of yore when you went out
into the wild and it was either the
thrill of life
or the agony of defeat right savannah
grad
exactly out there i'm out there tony
loving it back in the day back in the
day
um but do you think that people what
will that look like in 10 or 15 years if
no one's actually interacting
with another person in person they're
just meeting folks through
technology yeah this is a great question
and so even before the pandemic
according to research from stanford
meeting online was the number one place
that successful couples were meeting and
so this has been a trend that's going on
for a while but
the pandemic really increased it because
it was the only safe way
to meet during that time and i think
that we'll continue to see that but
what i hope that people are doing is
investing in in-person conversation
whether that's
hitting on somebody in public or having
a great first date right
the apps are just how you meet but once
you show up at that coffee bar or
go on a hike you are the one who has to
make conversation and so
let's continue to teach people how to do
that all right you heard it here first
the director of relationship science at
hinge logan yuri
endorsing hitting on somebody
thank you very much we appreciate it
we'll have you back soon thank you so
much i love how you know
we were talking earlier jamie asked us
what was our line
and i tried mine on you right wasn't a
line but i said you generally approach
somebody
and you have a wingman so you say this
guy thinks the beatles are better than
the rolling stones rolling stones and i
saw you
there you go so now we start having a
conversation about the stones why you
think they're
better than the beatles well i beatles
guy i can't believe my boyfriend
continued to date me because
we did the facetime and texting and
talking on the phone
we finally meet in person and i made him
answer 62 questions
what and we had a second day see you
later
and then he had one question which was
can we stop this
all right